on sunday the 10th of muharram
messengers arrived with letters
bearing word that 10 european ships had
reached the port of alexandria on
thursday the 8th and had stopped at such
a distance that the inhabitants of the
port could see them a short while later
another 15 ships had appeared the
inhabitants of the port had been
awaiting their messenger when suddenly a
boat came from these ships bearing ten
men
when they reached the shore the people
of the town spoke with them asking who
they were
they replied that they were english who
would come to inquire about the french
the people of the town told them no
french are with us except those who
reside in the port the english informed
them that the french had set out from
their country with a great fleet
we are their enemies and we do not know
what direction they intend to sail
perhaps they will attack you suddenly
and you will not be able to repel them
however al-saeed mohammed qurayim did
not believe their words and thought them
to be trickery the english thereupon
requested sell us water and provisions
according to their value and we shall
stay in our ships lying in wait for them
when they come we shall take care of the
matter and save you the trouble the
above mentioned muhammad qurayim
declined their offer and said we do not
accept what you say nor will we give you
anything
then he expelled them that god's will
might be fulfilled
on the third day more letters arrived
with words that the ships were no longer
visible so people calmed down and their
prattling ceased as for the amirs they
neither cared nor bothered themselves
with this matter
on wednesday the 20th of muharram news
and letters arrived from the ports of
alexandria rosetta and damanhur with
word that on monday the 18th the people
of the port suddenly realized that the
french and their ships had reached
al-ajami and were advancing on the town
at daybreak like a swarm of locusts
the people were excited and shouts
filled the air then the inhabitants of
the port attacked the french and fought
them fiercely as a result a great number
of the people of the port were killed
and the rest fled the kashif also fled
and saved himself meanwhile the french
continuously increased in number they
scaled the ruined parts of the walls
surrounding the port and entered it the
people looked about and suddenly found
the french behind them and withdrew and
haste seeking their homes only to
discover the french had occupied the new
manchia and had surrounded the walls
the people took refuge in the inns and
houses and locked themselves in others
fortified themselves and locked
themselves in the big tower in the
citadel firing continuously for some
time from the tops of the towers and
windows with bullets but their gunpowder
ran out and they were not at all
prepared
soon afterwards the notables of the town
went out to the french who received them
then they raised their flags which are
known among them as bandirat disarmed
the populace and had them sow their
emblem on their breasts
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
how many men and women were mobilized
during world war ii a 56 million b 127
million c 187 million that's correct 127
million 34 million of which were soviet
troops
and so my recommendation on magellan tv
this week is a great new arrival to the
platform ve day with tony robinson a
fascinating minute by minute exploration
of one of the most momentous days in
history full of interviews and great
insights it's a perfect way to learn
more about the conflict
and of course magellan have more than 3
000 other documentaries to check out too
it's a sort of netflix for documentaries
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voices of the past viewers
thanks
[Music]
during the course of these events gloom
spread among the populous and was felt
in the marketplaces and people withdrew
to their homes from sunset onwards
as a result the people publicly called
for the reopening of the markets and the
coffee houses and ordered the lamps
outside the houses and shops to be lit
once again this was done for two reasons
firstly to dispel the gloom and create
an atmosphere of ease and comfort and
secondly out of fear that an alien might
have free reign in the town
on monday news arrived that the french
had reached damanhur and rosetta
bringing about the flight of their
inhabitants to phua and its surroundings
contained in the news was mentioned of
the french sending notices throughout
the country demanding tax for the upkeep
of the military
furthermore they printed a large
proclamation in arabic
calling on the people to obey them and
raise their bandiera in this
proclamation were inducements warnings
all manner of wildiness and stipulations
some copies were sent from the provinces
of cairo
and its text is
in the name of god the merciful the
compassionate there is no god but god he
has no son nor has he an associate in
his dominion
on behalf of the french republic which
is based upon the foundation of liberty
and equality general bonaparte
commander-in-chief of the french armies
makes known to all the egyptian people
that for a long time the sanjaks who
loaded it over egypt have treated the
french community basely and
contemptuously and have persecuted its
merchants with all manner of extortion
and violence
thereupon the hour of punishment
has come
blessing on blessing to the egyptians
who will act in concert with us without
any delay for their condition shall be
rightfully adjusted and their rank
raised
but woe upon woe to those who will unite
with the mamluks and assist them in the
war against us for they will not find
the way of escape
and no trace of them
shall remain
[Music]
here is an explanation of the incoherent
words and vulgar constructions which he
put into this
miserable letter
their statement on behalf of the french
republic etc that is the proclamation
sent from their republic that means
their body politic because they have no
chief or sultan with whom they agree
like others whose function is to speak
on their behalf
when they rebelled against their sultan
six years ago and killed him the people
agreed unanimously that there was not to
be a single ruler but that their state
territories laws and administration of
their affairs should be in the hands of
the intelligent and wise men among them
they followed this rule great and small
high and low male and female are equal
sometimes they break this rule according
to their whims or inclinations or
reasoning
their women do not veil themselves but
have no modesty they do not care whether
they uncover their private parts
whenever a frenchman has to perform an
act of nature he does so wherever he
happens to be even in full view of
people and he goes away as he is without
washing his private parts after
defecation
if he is a man of taste and refinement
he wipes himself with whatever he finds
even with a paper with writing on it
otherwise he remains as he is
they have intercourse with any woman who
pleases them and vice versa sometimes
one of their women goes into a barber
shop and invites him to
shave her pubic hair if he wishes he can
take his fee in kind it is their custom
to shave both their mustaches and beard
some of them leave the hair on their
cheeks only they do not shave their
heads nor their pubic hair
they mix their foods
some might even put together in one dish
coffee
sugar iraq raw eggs limes and
so on
as for the name bonaparte this is the
title of their general
it is not a name
[Music]
a general call of arms was proclaimed
and the people were summoned to the
entrenchments the call was repeated time
and time again people closed their shops
and markets and everyone was in an
uproar the shakes the dignitaries and
the common people set out with clubs and
arms the price of arms gunpowder and
bullets increased greatly
on thursday the 28th news arrived the
french had advanced towards fua and then
al-rahmaniyah
news came that on friday the 29th the
egyptian army had encountered that of
the french but after a short while murad
bay and his army were routed for they
were not able to hold their ground
when saturday morning dawned and the
french reached um dinar the crowds
thickened and the alarm increased and an
innumerable throng surpassing all
description gathered at burak and on its
outskirts and in southern and northern
districts the soldiers and the mamluks
gathered on the two banks but they were
irresolute and were at odds with one
another being divided in opinion envious
of each other frightened for their lives
their well-being and their comforts
immersed in their ignorance and
self-delusion arrogant and haughty in
their attire and presumptuousness afraid
of decreasing in number and pompous in
their finery they were unlike the other
group that is the french who were a
complete contrast in everything
mentioned above
they acted as if they were following the
tradition of the community of muhammad
in early islam and saw themselves as
fighters of a holy war they never
considered the number of their enemy too
high nor did they care who among them
was killed
indeed they considered anyone who fled a
traitor to his community and an apostate
to his faith and creed
they follow the orders of their
commander and faithfully obey their
leader their food and drink is but a
morsel and a sip hanging under their
arms their only shade is the hat on
their head and their only mount their
own two feet
the egyptians went back and forth with
them for about three quarters of an hour
and the rifles of the french were like a
boiling pot on a fierce fire then the
egyptians were defeated and fled back to
algiza murad bay went up to his place
and attended to his affairs for about a
quarter of an hour then he rode
southwards
meanwhile the bank of bulac had become a
seething mass of people of every
description high and low they formed
into groups chewing their fingers out of
distress and sorrow because they could
not cross in the absence of ferry boats
all that they were able to do was to
raise cries of oh god oh god and our
sufficiency sufficiencies to god and he
is an excellent protector
the clamor and tumult reached such a
peak that it seemed as if they were
fighting a battle of noise and yells
knight fell and the inhabitants of the
city were in such great confusion and a
fantastic uproar in the evening a rumor
spread among the populace that the
french should cross to bulac and put it
to the torch
the fear and terror of the populace
waxed greater than ever so the people
were in great confusion and perplexity
in addition to the fear and panic and
alarm that possessed them some made up
their minds to move and took counsel to
this effect
those who had the means and could find a
donkey or some other beast brought it at
several times its value some went on
foot themselves whilst their wives and
daughters rode
most of the women left unveiled carrying
their children in the darkness of night
and continued in this fashion all
through sunday night and the next
morning they took with them all the
money baggage and household furnishings
they could carry but once they had left
the gates of cairo behind and were in
the open countryside the bedouin
confronted them plundering most of them
robbing them of their possessions their
camels and their money in such great
quantities as to be innumerable so much
so that without a doubt the property
which left cairo on that night was
greater than that which remained in it
general bonaparte crossed to the cairo
side and settled in the house of
mohammed bay al-alfi who had built and
constructed it that same year moreover
he had furnished it splendidly and had
laid down fine carpets the women had
left abandoning all it contained the
french entered it stepping on the
carpets with their shoes and sandals as
is their custom since they never take
off their shoes with which they tread
upon filth not even when they sleep
among their repulsive habits also is
their practice of spitting and blowing
their noses upon furnishings their
etiquette however is such that when
whenever one of them blows his nose or
spits he rubs it with his shoes and so
on
a number of english ships reached the
port of alexandria and fought a naval
battle with the french soldiers
several days had passed since the news
spread and it had already been discussed
by the people which embarrassed the
french and it happened that the same
shami christian merchants quoted
somebody by the name of saeed ahmad
al-zawi a merchant belonging to the khan
of soap merchants situated at al jamalia
as having discussed this affair
so the french ordered that he be brought
before them and reminded him of what he
had said but he denied it saying i heard
it from so and so the christian with the
result that they also brought him before
them and ordered that both of them have
their tongues cut out or did each one
pay 100 rial for answer
after that the people ceased to talk
about the french defeat
[Music]
at the end of that month the french
began to prepare for their feast
that is because when they killed their
sultan and their republic was proclaimed
according to the order they invented and
the rule which they created as was
mentioned before
they made that day the beginning of
their calendar and the feast
this day corresponds to the autumn
equinox in which the sun enters the
domicilium of libra
they also made a structure in the shape
of a great gate of lattice work and wood
they covered it with a painted cloth
like the one mentioned before and the
upper part of the basket was painted in
white with drawings in black
representing their soldiers fighting the
egyptians
you